I was going on a trip boy little tease
and I'm hated with leaves a report and
this is that's my guy
listen before we get started I just need
all you guys to remember I treated
myself without now so when we done with
this
I need a go or listen to every track on
that machine that and that's it as we
started first one he appeared on WWE Raw
he has his own emoji and he started a TV
show about his family I don't know check
it up to the Mellow ball I never seen
that he's from Boston
he says he's top five and a fourth night
basketball player and a 2k player he's
worked out with Melo Donovan Mitchell
Trey young this summer he's Kentucky's
first top five committing years
I don't know I don't know like I met him
before he's a son of a former NBA player
he's from New York City he hoops with
Jay Cole in North Carolina
he was in a documentary for Nick sports
called little Wallace and he has a
tattoo of his dad's UNLV Jersey on his
wall I don't know so this is kool-aid
from the city so do I get to know so
when you get to the lead know anybody he
plays on his high school basketball team
with another NBA star star
he loves tacos participates in Taco
Tuesday all the time Chris Paul's his
Godfather he wears number zero
he's been mobbed by fans in China and
his father is one of the best basketball
players in the world
Raul was it zero when you said his
father as my voice it was sufficient boy
little TJ this is this my guy and I'm
here bleacher for shooting myself is out
and now make sure you go tune in and
gangway highlights I did